what is going on everybody and welcome
to another Q&A video so first of all I
know people are gonna be like hey when's
the next chat bot tutorial coming out so
that's one of the questions I'm gonna go
ahead and answer right now and the
answer is I don't know so when I record
videos and do tutorial series I honestly
like generally I'll do a few to begin
with just to make sure this is a series
I really want to do there's been plenty
of series where I've done like a few
videos or just made try to come up with
a few things and immediately scrap the
entire project as long as I can get
through like the first few tutorials
then I can know relatively well one if
I'll be able to finish this this project
but also two if it's really something I
want to do and so that's why especially
recently a lot of times I release like
three four sometimes even like five
videos right out of the gate with a new
series and I do that for a few reasons
so one is just because I have the
content if I have it I'm not just going
to arbitrarily wait some time to release
the next video I don't really see huge
value in that so I've had a lot of
people try to instruct me and tell me
that's a bad idea the algorithm doesn't
like that you make more money if you if
you structure it one a day one I don't
think that's even true not at least not
from my channel but two I don't really
think it's the job of the Creator to try
to cater themselves to the algorithm
it's actually the algorithms job it's
Google and YouTube's job to make that
algorithm cater to the creator's and
find things so I feel the same way as
far as like websites are concerns like
you really shouldn't be trying to beat
the SEO what you should always just be
focus on is make great content that your
viewers love and at least for me when I
put myself in the shoes of a viewer
would I rather wait you know one day per
frickin video especially if the first
one was like an intro video that didn't
really get into anything no I don't
really want to wait through that you
know so if I can I'll push videos in
groups now sometimes I really did just
make the intro video or something like
that and that's all that gets published
or that's all I've edited or whatever
but yeah I don't really like to withhold
for algorithmic reasons
the next thing I get a lot is like how
many videos or what are you gonna cover
are you gonna do X again a lot of times
I don't know I'm making up things as I
go
I really don't sit down and plan a
syllabus or anything like that it was
one of the things that always frustrates
me when like companies come to me and
they want me to make a video series for
them or something and I'm just like I
don't I don't have a syllabus for you
and I don't really like doing it that
way if you like the content I put out
right now let's not do it that way
anyway so a lot of times I don't know
how many videos I might have a vague
idea like when I was doing the ML series
people were asking me how many videos is
this one gonna be
and I was like probably about 50 ish
plus because I just knew how many [ __ ]
like topics I plan to cover and I just
knew it's gonna be a lot all right with
the chat bot I don't know that's a that
could continue getting expanded on
forever and it really just depends on
what kind of traction that continues to
get as we continue making more videos so
hopefully that answers your questions on
when's the next chat bye tutorial how
many videos and really not just the chat
by tutorial but really any tutorial I
get that question all the time people
are asking when's the next one coming
out or whatever it just it really just
depends the next I want to talk about is
AMD so in one of the previous Q&A is
about what I use I mentioned that I
don't really have high regard for AMD
and then subsequently after that ambi
came out with the rise and stuff and
thread Ripper stuff and all that and
people were like hey what do you think
about gonna be now honestly their CPUs
their new CPUs are impressive
statistically they're putting out good
numbers they're the best CPUs at least
for like consumer type CPUs this really
should be like high up on your
considerations if you're building a new
computer their GPUs have made great
strides but I don't see why anybody
would buy their GPUs still like I would
not buy an AMD GPU I also had the
benefit of being able to talk to several
VP level people at AMD involved in their
processors and stuff and at least my
takeaway personally again this is a
single developer takeaway and I'm not
your average developer I don't work at
some big company
but my takeaway is that they're just
they're still like out of touch with
what a developer wants so for example
they've got their equivalent kind of of
like OpenCL which is quite CUDA but then
they also have that ROC stuff and the
problem is like people developed on top
of CUDA because there was no alternative
right so Andy's trying to get people to
develop on top of these this software
they put out but I don't think it's
gonna happen I just
I mean someone might especially if you
paid people to or something or there's
some sort of agreement there but the
reason why people be developed on top of
CUDA is that was the only option all
right so so nobody had any other choices
but nowadays I think anybody who has
that kind of skill set that might want
to develop on top of these kind of GPU
technologies especially for GPUs that
one that are inferior to Nvidia now that
might change like as we move forward
they might end up putting out GPUs that
are actually better just like they've
kind of supplanted Intel but also I mean
they've only supplanted Intel by one
generation pretty much of CPUs so I
would wait to see what kind of Intel's
answer is but I will say that Intel's
response has taken awhile so so who
knows I mean they really might have just
lost the lead and that would be an
interesting shift but anyways with GPUs
not seeing it and then also with their
GPU software I'm it's gonna be a really
big challenge for them and I don't think
they understand it again I only talked
to like three people there but I feel
like at the level those people were at
in that company I feel like they should
have
I don't know had a better grasp on on
the situation I just don't think they do
so as things would be after I got done
recording this I couldn't help but
notice the following news from Nvidia so
Nvidia just announced their new $3,000
Titan V the most expensive oh the most
powerful PC GPU effort created so yeah I
guess they throw on PC GPUs so they
don't conflict with the V 100 and other
GPU accelerators so what do you get with
your new 3,000 type dollar Titan V well
first of all it's
gold plated so you can feel pretty cool
also has the jagged edges so you can
continue feeling just as cool as you
have been feeling with like the Pascal
cards what else do we get though we get
yeah yeah 110 teraflop all 12 gigs of
VRAM why not 16 come on I understand
we're raising the bar as far as the type
of memory that we're using awesome I
also think we should be raising the bar
of the amount of VRAM epillow also we
get 50 120 cuda cores and 640 tensor
cores which sounds identical to the v
100 which it is identical to the V 100
another voltage chip same stats
basically one's an accelerator ones not
the accelerator comes with whoa what a
shocker 16 gigs of V ring so anyway I've
actually had the opportunity to use a
Tesla V 100 on actual model of mine and
actually a chatbot so the V 100 I would
say is about 75% faster than my 1080 Ti
so honestly when we're taking steps that
are 75% faster every time we step that's
incredible that's really cool now three
thousand dollars yeah come on man that's
that's sick that's pretty pricey I'm not
really sure it's worth $3,000 so another
way that Nvidia or AMD could take over
its just by making better bang for your
buck cards like I thought when when
Nvidia put out the 1080 Ti I was like
whoa like this is this is a card that's
undercutting all of their Titans and
honestly when this is $3,000 I feel like
the 1080 Ti is still undercutting this
card at least for me when I'm making
models like the biggest thing the thing
that inhibits cool models is the vram
that's the main concern I always have
when I'm building a model is how big of
a model can i stuff in the RAM now
obviously at some point we speed matters
right like obviously I could just buy a
bunch of RAM and actually just do things
with the CPU so I mean obviously speed
has a has it does matter a lot and it's
seventy-five percent speed-up I mean
that's real it's pretty cool but yeah
that's I feel like for $3,000 come on 16
gigs of VRAM please anyway just thought
I'd share that because I couldn't help
but notice that and thought yeah that's
pretty applicable but we were just
talking about anyway that's all finally
the last thing I want to talk about is
my new desk so I got a new stand
what's an adjustable desk but some
people have noticed that the angle has
changed and I've likely been standing in
the videos and I sure have so I got a 72
inch long adjustable standing desk by a
company called uplift desk not a sponsor
or anything but I'm totally sold on this
desk I've thought about doing a review
on it I just I don't know if I really
feel like doing that but if you're
interested or curious about standing
desks I highly suggest you check them
out you can get a pretty small one like
a three footer or something like that
for relatively cheap like four or five
hundred bucks if I recall right but
thinking obviously as you get bigger and
bigger they're gonna get more expensive
I love the big test
but yeah anyway I'm super happy with the
standing desk I thought I would get it
and only stand like maybe 20 minutes
every couple hours or something like
that but Ashley it's been the opposite
basically I don't even put the stuff
down like I'll go entire days just
standing all day and I just love it and
if you're if you're like someone who
runs or anything like that like I used
to get horrible foot pain and I really
think and I even there's like calves my
calves would like cramp at night and my
toes would cramp too and I honestly
think it's because I even though yeah I
was a runner and I did exercise and
stuff I would come home basically and
just sit and the muscles would just get
tight whereas if you're standing or
actually just you know you're not using
a ton of your muscles but you are using
some muscles to stay standing obviously
that's been huge impact like that might
actually be the biggest impact that the
standing desk is made and I didn't I
didn't get it for that reason I just
wanted to improve posture so it was
really hard for me to have any decent
posture I'm pointing to my old desk you
can't see it but anyway I couldn't have
a decent posture there so
anyway really like the desk highly
suggest check them out like I said it's
an automatic desk you can like press
certain buttons on the there's like a
control pad you can make it go up and
down but then you can also save presets
so I have like a standing in a sitting
preset but you know like when I eat for
example sometimes I want the desk if I'm
eating at the desk I try not to eat up
my computer too often but sometimes you
do and I'd like it to be a little taller
than normal and stuff it's it's pretty
cool to have a desk that you can adjust
like that so anyway yes I did get a new
desk yes it's a standing desk but it's
well it's adjustable but yeah it's
amazing also when I bought the desk just
in case anybody is interested make sure
you get the little foot mat like mine
just came with one and I don't know if
they're all gonna come with them but
that's like the only reason I can stand
all day at the desk if I didn't have
this little foot mat your feet would
just get super sore but somehow like
especially if you can stand on it
barefoot like obviously if you're at an
office or something you probably can't
get away with that but if you can stand
barefoot on top of this little foot mat
thing that they send with the desk or if
they don't send it you can probably add
it on that thing is worth at least a
hundred dollars I think it's like maybe
15 20 bucks if you have to add it on but
at least my desk it just I didn't have a
choice but anyway uh I think that's all
for now if you guys have any follow-up
questions that you want me to answer in
a QA or you have some more follow-up
questions that you about things that
I've asked here or answered here feel
free to leave those questions below
otherwise I'll see you in another video